programa número 42 de la siguiente
región circular las dos secciones no
sombreadas constituyen tres séptimos y
un tercio del área total del círculo que
el porcentaje del círculo es la parte
sombreada el área sombreada va a ser el
área total menos estas dos áreas no
sombreadas digamos que el área total es
uno digamos que uno es el área total
vamos a restarle las otras fracciones va
a ser uno menos tres séptimos
nos un tercio y el resultado será esta
área sombreada vamos a desarrollarlo
veamos el común denominador 7 por 3 será
21 así que pongo 21 acá 21 por 1 va a
ser 21 y 21 entre 1 va a ser 1 un entero
aquí cumplimos esto menos 7 por 3 21 3
por 3 9 921 abós es igual a 3 séptimos
menos un tercio es igual a 7 veintiuna
vamos
ok vamos a resolver esto menos 9 menos 7
va a ser menos 16 21 menos 16 entre 21
hacemos está resta va a ser igual a 5
entre 21 esta es la opción de 521 vos
de la circunferencia veamos el siguiente
problema
nos piden resolver esta operación punto
3 a la quinta entre punto 3 al cubo esto
es lo mismo que tener punto 3 a la
quinta por punto 3 a la menos 3 ya saben
que cuando se divide en cantidades con
exponentes estos se van a restar y
cuando se multiplican los exponentes
semanas más así que esto es igual a esto
es igual a 0.3 al cuadrado
5 - tres igualados y esto lo
desarrollamos punto tres por punto 3
9 y tenemos dos lugares decimales si que
va a ser 12 aquí va el punto y equipo
nos un 0.09 que es nuestra opción se
siguiente problema
número 44 en un experimento de
horticultura 200 semillas se siembran en
el semillero 1 y 300 semillas se
siembran en el semillero 2 si el 57% de
las semillas en el semillero 1 al
germinado y el 42% de las semillas en el
semillero 2 han germinado también cual
porcentaje del total de las semillas
sembradas con germinar
vamos a expresar esto nos dicen que en
el semillero 1 se sembraron 200 semillas
de estas terminaron el 57%
g de que germinar en el semillero 2 se
sembraron 300 semillas de las cuales han
germinado el 42 por ciento
g de que germinaron entonces lo que nos
piden es el 57% de 200 que es 200 por
punto 57
más este porcentaje el 42% de 300 que va
a ser 300 por 0.42 entre el total de las
semillas sembradas que fueron 300 más
200 500 500 semillas para simplificar
los cálculos vamos a dividir numeradores
denominador entre 100 esto si lo hago
así lo divide en tres y me va a quedar 2
por 0.57 más 3 por 0.42
entre 2 perdón entre 5 ya me está
emocionando con el 2 entre 5 muy bien es
el más sencillo de operar 2 por punto 57
va a ser igual
1.14
3 por punto 42
va a ser igual a 1.26
entre 5 hacemos esta suma que nos da
12.4 en 35 y ahora vamos a hacer esta
división vamos a decir por acá 2.4 en 35
aquí tenemos nuestro punto decimal aquí
comenzamos 5 por 4 20 menos 24 me quedan
4 aquí pongo un 0 8 por 5 es 40 40 menos
40 va a ser igual a cero así que mi
respuesta es punto 48 o el 48% del total
de las semillas sembradas ha germinado
que es nuestra opción
bien hacemos el siguiente problema muy
bien número 45 3 y 8 son las longitudes
de dos lados en una región triangular
cuál o cuáles de los siguientes podrían
ser la longitud del tercer lado tenemos
la primera opción 5 bueno puedo
imaginarme un triángulo que tenga tres
de un lado ocho de otro lado y cinco
de otro lado eso se podría dar
así que la primera opción es viable la
segunda 8 pues también me podía imaginar
un triángulo isósceles con los lados
iguales de 8 me puedo imaginar un
triángulo que tenga un lado de 8 otro
lado de 8 y aquí uno de 3 esta segunda
opción si podría ser también la tercera
opción
interesante déjeme preguntarle si esto
es posible tener un triángulo que sea
no sé vamos a dibujarlo así 3 8 y 11
pues no porque 83 es 11 y la única
manera de que este tercer lado sea 11 es
que ustedes tomen este punto de acá y lo
acerquen lo más posible
hasta esta parte tanto que se vuelva al
lugar de un triángulo pues una línea
sencilla imagínense un lado así otro
lado así y éste así de manera que éste
sea 3 desde este 8 a menos que estos dos
se unan por completo aquí y formen una
línea que de 11 este lado tendrá por
fuerza que ser menor a la suma de estos
dos porque esta línea une estos dos
extremos así que no puede ser la opción
y de las respuestas nos dan las opciones
1 y 2
estas son las viables esta es nuestra
respuesta que es la opción c
siguiente problema
número 46 cuartos enteros m existen de
tal manera que uno sea menor que cinco
por n 5 y esto a su vez sea menor a 25
notamos que no dice que deban ser
enteros positivos este es un problema
interesante vamos a simplificar vamos a
restar 5 de toda esta desigualdad menos
cinco más uno va a ser igual a menos
cuatro que es menor a cinco n 5 menos
cinco quedan 5 n que es menor a 25 5 es
igual a 20
ahora dividamos todo entre 5 y como es
positivo no vamos a tener que cambiar el
sentido de esta desigualdad esto entre 5
esto entre 5 y esto entre 5 es igual a
menos cuatro quintos
menos que 5 n entre 5 es n menor a 20
entre 5 es 44 y ahora esto es más
sencillo de resolver cuantos enteros de
n cumplen con esta desigualdad que están
entre menos cuatro quintos y 4 veamos
cero es un entero no puedo como esto
estamos hablando de entero no puedo
tener nada menor que cero así que cero
es un entero uno es un entero dos es un
entero tres es otro entero y hasta acá
tenemos un 12 34 enteros que cumplen con
esta desigualdad y es nuestra opción b
siguiente problema problema número 47 un
vendedor de autos vendió x autos usados
y autos nuevos en el mes de mayo si el
número de autos usados vendidos es 10
autos más que el número de autos nuevos
vendidos cuál de las siguientes expresa
esta relación bueno expresar esto en una
ecuación es bastante sencillo tenemos
que la cantidad de autos usados que es x
es igual a la cantidad de autos nuevos
vendidos más 10 y resulta que esta es
nuestra opción d
veamos el último problema de este vídeo
problema número 48 si en un depósito del
10% fue pagado para la compra de cierto
producto y es de 110 cuánto es lo que
falta por pagar esto esencialmente es
110 es el 10% de qué cantidad es decir
110 es igual al 10% d
el precio del producto que lo desconozco
lo voy a llamar p de precio del producto
cual será este bueno para saber el
precio del producto vamos a despejar nos
queda que p es igual a 110 entre 0.1 y
esto es igual a 1100
bien este es el precio original pero nos
preguntan cuánto falta por pagar después
del primer depósito así que a esta
cantidad 1100 de vamos a restar 110
qué es lo que fue del primer depósito
nos va a quedar 09
9 990 que es nuestra opción b nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo